oh you you gave up the first pick
tomorrow as well all right first pick
goes to me and let's begin with the
seattle seahawks this is something we
have talked about repeatedly this is
something that we are alarmed about
because they had an opportunity to get
everson griffin and they chose not to
the seahawks pass rush how is this team
going to survive if they can't put heat
on the opposing quarterback because you
eventually are going to come across a
team in the postseason that may do to
you what the cardinals did the other
night maybe it'll be the cardinals that
cross paths with the seahawks at some
point in the postseason and do that same
thing so without question i mean this is
a given the seahawks pass rush is a
weakness a glaring hole that could bring
down the whole season for the team
eventually uh a hundred percent no doubt
about it um they're
really
we could pick another position for the
seahawks and probably pick their
secondary as well their corners i mean i
could easily make that my pick but i'm
not going to but yeah it's concerning it
really is
no pass rush cab nobody really that can
play man-to-man other than quentin
dunbar he's the only guy that's really
got any real fighting chance there they
got issues i mean man it's gonna be all
about russ and it ain't gonna change so
we'll see where that goes i think the
next one i'm gonna go to i'm gonna go to
the the titans and the same thing i'm
going to their pass rush i mean
they get seven sacks you know their
defense is obviously an issue but i'm
going to go with their pass rush as
being the biggest issue because that
compromises them a lot they're stuck in
like wait do we want a blitz or do we
want to drop back and play coverage and
and do those type of things but you know
gideon connie being there has done
nothing for their pass rush really
harold landry's the only guy that pops
up off the edge every now and then and
that's nothing special really jeffrey
simmons their defensive tackles their
best pass rusher he's their best player
on defense in general all together he is
a stud but that is really worrisome you
know especially
in the afc when they're holding
themselves to the high regard we think
we're a super bowl team and you know
you're gonna have to play the chiefs and
you don't have a team that can rush the
passer or anybody that could ever you
know
run down in my homes or anything like
that um that would be concerning
see i had the titans on my list but
special teams is my concern the
goskowski field goal misses in all these
close games yeah that goofy brett kern
low snap took off and started to run and
then threw a pass when he should have
known
all the offense was down field illegally
he had time to do a rugby kick he could
have gotten the ball out of there so
they've got special teams issues that
could hurt them especially in close
games next one for me the packers lack
of weapons period look and and they were
fortunate last week the point you've
made houston never reacted to the
possibility maybe we should double team
devante adams but they just they don't
have the past catchers
that make it easier for aaron rodgers to
do what he needs to do and uh period
that's what they need that's what they
don't have and that's eventually you
know the one-man band concept is
eventually going to potentially bring
them down right because they're going to
come up against a team where aaron just
can't do it all by himself
that's exactly it you know you're
exactly right i mean they're another
team just like the seahawks where i got
the packers written down and i got the
defensive tackles or run defense that's
the thing that i scared so they got two
flaws
you know it brings me back to earlier in
the show when you were talking about
yeah michael mccarthy brought lesser
teams and to beat the cowboys and i'm
going to go yeah well i was going to
interrupt you and go yeah they did but
they had this guy number 12 at
quarterback okay who kind of was like
the e the equalizer there but yeah i
mean i'm i'm with you the the weapons
whatever the packers are certainly one
of the teams on my list and it's why i
don't really hold them in a
legit
super bowl
regard i don't do you mike i mean i look
at them and go damn they're dangerous
it'd have to fall the right way in the
playoffs because they're not going to
beat the bucks they're not going to beat
the saints i don't think they can beat
the 49ers if they get in the playoffs
that's to me i don't think they could
beat the rams either
they'd have to be lucky to how it falls
and shakes out for them as far as
matchups are concerned all right um
after after they beat the texans aaron
rodgers said that the loss to the bucks
last week week six was an anomaly the
problem is
they have those when they go on the road
against great teams exactly right they
can't they can't they can't beat those
teams and they get blown out by those
teams all right go ahead no but you're
right i mean it's it's teams with good
defenses the defensive lines i mean or
just good offensive lines too they
steamroll them whether it was the 49ers
both last year you know the chargers
d-line in that game last year out there
in la that was an issue so that's a real
point all right um i think i got to go
with the bears you know the bears
it's something offensive related i mean
it kind of all stinks
all right but i'll go with their
offensive line as being the biggest
issue i mean i could pick matinee
certainly because the scheme itself is
as boring as crap as well but the really
big issues are their offensive line they
have they're not great in pass pro they
don't move anybody in the run game you
know like i said nagi doesn't give them
any schematical advantages there either
but i think between that and the running
back combination yeah it's just that
bears a line it's very underwhelming it
really puts them behind the eight ball
when they have to play good teams
yeah and and look i don't even consider
the bears i know well contender that
even gets into the conversation record
notwithstanding well i was gonna say
like where do i draw the line here as
far as the draft is concerned i mean
they are you know five and two but i i'm
with you i'm the same thing i mean
that's why i wasn't sure like to add
them in this or not i didn't know where
to go there
well i'm gonna go with the team that's
four and two the saints lack of a
downfield passing game i mean we've seen
that all year long and at some point
that is going to hurt them at some point
they're going to go up against the
defense it's going to take away
everything underneath with or without
michael thomas and and it's you know you
can't just flip it out to taysom hill
and say throw it 50 yards that doesn't
seem to be working this year they need
that downfield threat to keep the
defense honest and we know they don't
have it and that's the thing that could
keep them from from getting back to a
super bowl they've been try i got to
give them credit every year they keep
coming back
they have the heartbreaking loss in the
postseason they keep coming back they
keep coming back but i think that that
is going to keep them from getting to
where they want to be yeah i i hear you
there it's scary too you're right it's
it's all it's it's a little bit like
yeah it's going to be the right match up
or you get scared if yeah okay this team
comes into town and takes away those
short passes and things like that can
they beat you and we've seen that what
is that three years in a row really that
that kind of team is the team that beats
them in the playoffs and that is uh
definitely concerning no doubt about it
i i don't know where to go here
i really don't i because i don't want to
pick some of the teams that are like the
browns or the cardinals quite yet i mean
i want to stay towards the top tier
football teams i do and i think we got a
lot of those out of the way i'm one with
the rams and the ravens i'm gonna go
with the ravens all right
i'm gonna go with the ravens
and
the passing game lamar jackson i'm just
going to say it it's got to be really
good here down the stretch they are
going to play some teams that can stop
their run game and they won't be able to
be the bully and listen the bottom line
is mike we're holding baltimore in a
super bowl level right that's the
expectations we have for them the bottom
line is it has to get better if they
want to beat the chiefs in the playoffs
the afc championship game whatever it is
the run game and greg roman's tricks and
all that just can't win every game at
some point you're gonna meet your
kryptonite and you're gonna have to have
something for that kryptonite and that's
the next thing we need to see from the
ravens legit yeah they're achilles yeah
achilles hill literally is the
possibility of facing the chiefs in the
post season right that's it that was
what i had on my list i had one more
that i just have to mention
and i love tom brady
greatest of all time but this
personality cult that's gradually
developing around the buccaneers and
he's the center of the universe and he
gets what he wants and oh he
he knew it was fourth down all that
stuff
that that could come back to haunt them
at some point there's too much power
vested in one guy and there's too many
people running around making excuses for
him and giving them everything you want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports